Drip, drip, drip.
It's springtime in the Pacific Northwest.
How delightful.
It's often said, by me,
that if you can't make
it in Silicon valley,
then you head to Seattle.
And if you can't make it
there, you go to Vancouver.
There's a reason housing prizes
are only mildly insane in these parts
as opposed to totally
insane in Silicon Valley.
You have to put up with things
like weather, Jeff
Bezos's big silver spheres
and tourist spots where people
throw fish at your face.
Still, as a Californian,
I'm willing to concede
that the Pacific Northwest
might have some merits.
I mean, this is decent.
And this pizza designed by a wizard
probably tastes pretty good.
And so I have set out on a road trip
from Seattle to Vancouver
to find out why people
choose to live here.
Why they have given their souls
over to Microsoft and Amazon.
And why they're so open
about caging humans
and machines like this,
just so they can build our
dead eyed replacements.
Tourists would probably start
their trip hanging out in Seattle.
But I'm a tech dork with
a time lapse to make.
And so we're going ahead
east to Redmond and Bellevue
also known as the towns
that Microsoft built.
Microsoft's headquarters in Redmond
has all the we're doing
technology essentials.
There are slogans, and more slogans.
There's a garage placed
randomly inside of an office
because startups come from garages.
There are buildings and more buildings.
And there are treehouses
where engineers go
to meditate on how to next level excel
and how to let Skype keep languishing.
Nearby Bellevue is similar,
but kind of ritzier.
This for example, is the shopping mall
in the bad part of town.
I have come to Bellevue to see this thing.
But mostly to meet the
man who paid for it.
How are you Nathan?
Great, how are you doing?
Nathan Myhrvold.
Yeah, likewise.
Nathan is the former
Chief Technology Officer at Microsoft.
Today, he's perhaps best known
as the world's most curious human.
This is a microscope that I built.
These are commercial microscopes
that I then heavily modified.
And this is a solar telescope.
You can see incredible amounts of detail
of the sun churning.
Now this device here is a Panorama Robot.
I use this for taking landscape pictures.
And this is a four camera
array that we built.
This goes onto this mount here,
and that mount slowly goes
across the sky at night.
So you track the stars.
So what we see are these
wonderful long meteor that-
Nathan really does do a bit of everything.
And he does everything to the extreme.
He's an accomplished paleontologist
and has dug up numerous
dinosaur skeletons.
But just finding the bones is not enough.
So back in 1997, I was interested
in the following question which is,
there are a bunch of the dinosaurs
called Sauropod dinosaurs
which had really long skinny necks.
So Apatosaurus, also called Brontosaurus
sometimes is an example.
Those had really long skinny tails.
And a British biomechanics expert,
he wondered if they could
have been used to make noise.
So I made a computer
model that showed that
in fact, the tail of
these Sauropod dinosaurs
could actually act like
a whip, a bull whip.
Now the way a bull whip makes
that cracking noise.
Yeah.
Is because the tip of the whip
actually goes about twice
the speed of sound.
Okay.
And that crack is a sonic boom.
So I published a paper on this in 1997.
It was well received,
but also controversial.
A lot of dinosaur
paleontologists said, well,
I won't believe it until
you build a physical model.
I said, okay, you wanna physical model?
I'll make a physical model.
So this replicates the
tail of a Apatosaurus.
And so the idea is as
this animal would walk,
this very long very thin tail
could be made whip around.
We have a high speed video camera.
We have shown with that
high speed video camera
that this went mock too.
Do they think it's like a defense thing
or like to make noise to signal?
Well, okay, so it turns
out half of the specimens
of this kind of dinosaur
have intervertebral damage
at about number 23, somewhere down here.
It turns out that same area
is the area where a bull whip wears out.
So about half the specimens
were whipping their tails.
Oh wow.
So often that they damaged their bones.
Which totally sounds
like male behavior to me.
I think the way they got a date
was to impress the females
by making loud booms.
And if you do a scaling argument,
you can show that the noise
would've been deafening.
Like as loud as the big
guns on the USS New Jersey.
So here's the other interesting
thing about wild animals.
You can't know for sure
what you're going to get.
Nathan also likes to photograph wildlife.
I decided I wanted to photograph all
of the wild cats and
wild dogs in the world.
But all the species, no,
the individuals.
Yeah.
So this is a camera trap.
So this is a camera that you
set up and you leave out there
and it gets automatically
triggered if the animal walks by.
That's really great
for really shy animals.
And unfortunately, most
wild cats are really shy.
And this is a rig that
we call the three Amigos.
So we have three, 600 millimeter lenses.
We have wired them together
with electronics box that we build.
So with this, I can take a picture
which will simultaneously be
taken by all three cameras.
And that allows me to make a big panorama.
I see, sure.
Of a moving subject.
Okay.
So these are Sandhill Cranes.
There's tens of thousands
of them in this one photo.
You couldn't get a picture
like this without that rig.
And Nathan is into snowflakes as well.
Like, really into snowflakes.
Most of the water that
we consume falls as snow.
Okay, the reason we get any
water at all in the summer
in the Northwest is cause
the snow pack is melting.
And I'd done a lot of microscopy.
So, oh this is great.
I'll take some pictures of snowflakes.
Well, it turns out that's really hard.
So after lots of experimentation
and effort, we built this.
So you have to catch the snowflake and-
And here's how you catch a snowflake.
This is a very delicate sable brush.
And you put this down,
and as it gets close to the snowflake,
static electricity makes
the snowflake jump up
and it touches that.
And then it's in here is-
And then we put it on here
and we have to put it on a slide
that's made out of artificial sapphire.
Then we have our lighting rig
made with an exotic set
of light emitting diodes.
Which we're able to pulse very, very fast.
Then we have a computer
controlled mechanism
and it takes a series of pictures quickly.
So this is some of the results.
And these are actually the
highest resolution photographs
of snowflakes ever taken on
our first snowflake shoot.
When the first one came out,
I turned to my two
compatriots who were with me.
I said, look, I don't know how great
this is gonna be going forward,
but we definitely have our
Christmas card for this year.
These days, Nathan spends
a lot of his time in the kitchen.
He's an accomplished chef who has produced
a stunning series of cookbooks
called Modernist Cuisine.
The books are famous for how big they are.
They're amazing photos.
And the science and
techniques they describe.
Nathan's most recent
book centers on pizza.
Well, pizza's probably
the single most popular dish on earth.
The other thing about pizza is that
there's tons of lore and legend
and oh, you can't make pizza
unless you have the water of Naples
or your oven was constructed
of special stone quarry near Naples.
Those sorts of myths and legends
are one of the things
that we love to dig into
because sometimes there's
a germ of truth to it.
In which case it's really interesting.
And in other cases, it's just hooey.
So this is our pizza scanner.
Okay.
So it turns out there's
different things you can do
in the crust on different
techniques of baking
that'll make the rim either
puffier or less puffy.
Well, I wanted to measure that.
So it's putting a structured
light field on it.
Very much like a light
arm in a self-driving car.
And this one, this is through stretching.
So this is a called a texture analyzer.
What this is does, is
it presses on a subject
and it measures the force as it presses.
And so you get a force
versus displacement curve.
And from that curve you can tell off
the crispiness or chewiness
What else do we have?
We got a centrifuge.
What do you use this for?
So here is ground up peas.
So this is frozen peas
from the supermarket
and we puree them into goo.
Well, then when you spin them
in the centrifuge you get this.
And you can like extract that out
and make that this concentrated
sort of essence of-
Yes, and it's fantastic.
And then this is called
a rotary evaporator.
Rotary evaporators are
basically used for distillation.
So we have got some tomatoes
that we have ground up.
It spins in here and we suck a vacuum
and then we carefully cool it.
And that allows us to concentrate it.
And here is the concentrate.
So I would invite you to taste some.
Should taste like a fresh tomato.
Wow, yeah.
Nathan's pizza pal is Francisco Migoya.
He's a world class pastry chef
who used to work at French Laundry.
I'm gonna make a couple
pizzas for you to see.
We're gonna do not classical
toppings on them as well,
so that you can see more or less-
Science the shit
out of this pizza.
Okay.
Actually hand us a double.
So it's gotta be very supple,
but it's also very light.
That's because we've allowed it
to slowly build up the gas in it.
We always ferment overnight
in a refrigerator.
It makes a huge, huge difference.
So it really should be very supple.
You see how Francisco is working on that.
Yeah, yeah.
So we're basically trying to stretch this
without making a tooth in either.
We're trying to leave also a bit of a rim.
Cause this is gonna puff up when it bakes.
This is basically an Alfredo sauce
that you would typically put in pasta.
It's one of favorites.
And this is smoke paprika mozzarella.
Fresh mozzarella.
Oh, wow, okay.
Yeah, we made a whole set of
our own flavored mozzarellas.
All right, so I'm gonna go
in the oven now.
Okay.
How hot is it?
This is at 840 Fahrenheit.
So there you have it.
Smells amazing.
So this is Iberico Ham.
We also did the pea butter.
That's what we put on
top and some pea shoots.
Okay, well let's try some.
It's delicious.
I like kind of the saltiness
of the ham with the pea.
And that's like the best
crust I think I've ever had.
I mean, so light.
Yeah, and there's so much flavor in there.
You've time for another one?
Yes please.
Yep, okay.
So here we have an ingredient
called pressure caramelized zucchini.
We've pressure cooked it, and
we've added some baking soda.
And the reason is the reactions
that cause food to brown.
A chemist would say it
was the Maillard Reaction.
So if you add some baking soda
and pressure cook the zucchini,
the natural sugars and
zucchini will maillardize
and that puts a unique flavor in it.
It's really good.
I mean, you're not gonna,
you have no motivation,
like open up pizza place or-
So my usual joke is, as a cookbook writer,
I'm familiar with one capital intensive,
often money losing business.
I don't need to be in a second one.
Yeah.
But if you're passionate
and curious about pizza,
you will learn all kinds
of things in the book
you'll find nowhere else
Were there some things you've discovered
that were kind of myths about pizza?
The water that we used to make a pizza.
We made pizza with water
from a swimming pool.
Now, I don't recommend
that you use swimming
pool water, but it worked.
Didn't kill the yeast.
Away from the kitchen,
Nathan heads up Intellectual Ventures.
It's a very controversial company
that hires very bright
people to think up ideas.
Like people literally sit in a
room and think up inventions.
And then Intellectual
Ventures patents the ideas.
Nathan says he does this
to let ideas flourish.
Other people say he's a patent troll
because he's trying to collect
as many big ideas as possible
so that IV can charge
people for access to them.
So there were a bunch of tech companies,
particularly large tech companies
that had the attitude of look,
if we wanna use ideas in our products,
that's our prerogative.
Who the hell are you, inventor?
All you did was come up with the idea.
I think that if you create a situation
where big tech companies can steal
any invention they want
to, that's not right.
It's morally not right.
But I think it's also less efficient
at getting new ideas for the world.
Yeah, so you actually were born in Seattle
but grew up in Southern California.
Yeah, that's right.
My joke is that I'm like a salmon.
I had to come back to
the home stream to spawn.
I know by the time you were 14,
I think you'd already skipped four grades
and graduated high school
and you were heading off to college.
You pursued a couple fields
of very hardcore science.
I have a bachelor's degree, a master's,
a second master's and a PhD.
And they're all in different topics.
But the last one was physics.
And I was a postdoc with
Steven Hawking at Cambridge.
And then I wound up starting
a software company in 1983.
Then Microsoft acquired our company.
Then went to work for Bill Gates.
So you're not a computer
scientist by training.
You get to Microsoft, you end up
as the Chief Technology Officer.
But then you have all these
interests clearly as we can see.
So is that what was
bubbling inside of you.
Just this need to go off and try.
Go explore all these things
that you're fascinated by.
I loved my time at Microsoft.
But I did have to put 90% of
my waking time into one thing.
And I am naturally interested
in lots of other things.
One of the biggest things you have pursued
at Intellectual Ventures and
through sort of your friendship
and various partnerships with Bill Gates,
a lot of it's around climate change
and technology related to that.
You've had big ideas around geoengineering
and I've seen you guys talk
about the filling the
atmosphere with particles to-
Well, so here's a way to
think about global warming.
Sunlight leaves the sun.
It comes roaring across the
93 million miles of space.
It hits earth.
Some of it then is re-radiated
as infrared radiation.
And then infrared radiation comes up
and it hits CO2 in the
atmosphere and it gets stuck.
That's what global warming is about.
Well, the amount of energy
the sun is depositing here on earth
is about 300 watts per square meter.
The amount of extra
radiation that is trapped
by this extra CO2 in an atmosphere
is somewhere within two and
three watts per square meter.
It's 1%.
So it's a little effect, but of course
it compounds across all of earth.
And that keeps building up over time
and that's what eventually screws you.
Well, that means one approach to this
is we just have to make the sun 1% dimer.
Well, how do you control the sun?
The answer is you could control that
by putting particles
in the high atmosphere.
And human eyes really aren't
sensitive to a 1% change.
You need almost a factor
of two change in light
for us to see a difference.
So if we bounced that off,
you literally couldn't tell here on earth
that you'd done it.
There's another set of
ideas that are about
how you could capture CO2
directly out of the atmosphere.
Many parts of the ocean
are very nutrient poor.
They're nutrient poor
primarily cause they lack iron.
So you can do something
called iron fertilization.
You put dissolved iron,
similar to what a human
would take for an iron
supplement if you're anemic.
And you put that into the sea water
and immediately enormous
amounts of plankton bloom.
Those blooming plankton feed lots of fish.
So you help the whole ecosystem that way.
But then quite a bit of those plankton die
and they fall down to
the bottom of the ocean,
carrying their carbon with them.
I mean, I think the general idea, probably
that a lot of people have is
we do something like that
just by nature of being humans
we're gonna **** it up even worse somehow.
Well, maybe it turns out
that geoengineering has
got such bad side effects,
we never decide to use it.
But we gotta know.
There's a lot of people
in the climate community
that hate mention of geoengineering.
Right.
A lot of climate folks
think that if only we
stopped driving SUVs,
lived simple lives, et cetera.
We could just decide to
not have climate change.
The trouble is climate
change isn't a decision.
There's some very hard physics.
So you can't just say,
oh, we'll all go green.
And it'll all be great.
And we don't have to ever
worry about geoengineering
2050 is a date for various reasons
that gets focused on a lot.
So it's 2050, are we ****ed
or are we okay?
What's your, If you're betting.
I think by 2050 we will have
very substantial temperature increase.
And we will either have enormous
environmental consequences,
huge loss of human life or both.
And I think we really need to say
what are our alternatives.
Because with the crazy
time scales of this problem
there's no other way to bridge that gap.
It was more fun eating the pizza.
Next up, I head to the open seas
and then into the heart of Seattle
to learn how to afford a house here.
We bought it for $350,000,
transform the place,
and then we put it back on.
Sold it in four days for about $450,000.